I don't know if we don't spend a whole
bunch of time holding hands stop making
excuses okay got it it's already the
hardest part yeah I'm gonna have to wait
to compare but I feel like this hand
might be too small so nerve wracking oh
this is so hard now I'm like Goldilocks
I feel like this hand might be a little
too big could be could be mad
Santa's definitely colder than the other
hands that's my first observation so
that makes me feel like it could not be
him but I don't know the size feels
right on this one it's equally as soft
as the other everyone's had really soft
hands today yeah okay I think I'm I
think I'm ready to guess I think Matt is
hands number three you got it
well done babe I was nervous there for a
second I thought it was a horrible
boyfriend it would have been okay if he
had gotten I would have made dinner or
something yeah when I felt hand three I
I knew I don't know if I could have done
it I mean
his fingers kind of give it away but
it's your alien face fingers